hello this is presh talwalkar and i'm
going to teach you how to solve the
rubik's cube
in the first video i'm going to explain
how you solve the cube by cheating this
is not so you actually cheat but it's to
explain the anatomy of the cube
in the videos to follow i'm going to
explain the move notation and then i'm
going to explain the layer method
in which you solve the cube
layer by layer
by solving the first layer then the
middle layer and then the final layer
the rubik's cube is a 3d puzzle
and it's one of the best selling toys of
all time
there are six faces with different
colors
you can move the cube around and move
the colors around
and what makes the aerobics cube such an
interesting
problem is that even after a few moves
the colors get mixed up quite thoroughly
what makes it frustrating is that when
you try and put the cube back together
if you don't know what you're doing it
seems like the cube only gets mixed up
more
so in dire frustration you might be
tempted to cheat and that's what we're
going to do right now
i'm going to take the cube apart and
then reassemble the pieces in their
correct positions
now a few words of caution i don't
recommend doing this as you can see it's
actually frustrating sometimes it's not
that easy to do
the other problem is that it's going to
take us nearly 10 minutes to take it
apart and then put it back together
if instead you follow the instructions
in the videos that follow you'll be able
to solve the cube in just a couple
minutes
and it'll be far more impressive
than if you cheated
alright once i have one piece that's
wedged out i'm going to slowly remove
the rest of the pieces and take the
rubik's cube apart
i'm going to do this slowly because it's
very easy to lose a piece in this
process or they'll fly everywhere
but the reason i'm doing this
it's not just to cheat and get to a
solved position because i know how to
solve the cube
but the point is i want to show you the
anatomy or the skeleton of the rubik's
cube
there are six faces
which have different colors
and these faces what's important is that
they do not move
these pieces are completely fixed and
the point of solving the rubik's cube is
you want to move the remaining pieces to
match them
so the white face will always be
opposite the yellow face
the orange face will be opposite the red
and the blue face and green faces will
be opposite each other
so you might be able to rotate the
pieces but they'll never be able to move
into other positions
now before i put the cube back together
i'm going to sort the pieces
you can think about this like solving a
jigsaw puzzle where you separate the
pieces into corner pieces edge pieces
and middle pieces
for the rubik's cube there's a similar
grouping that we're going to use
some of the pieces will have white on
them which means they're going to have
to match
the white center face and we know those
pieces can all be put in a group
other pieces will be yellow and that
means they'll have to go on the side
that's opposite the white face where
there's a yellow center
some of the pieces will neither have
white nor yellow
and those pieces will go in the center
there's one further subdivision of the
pieces which is some of the pieces will
be corner pieces
which will have three colors on them and
some of them will be edge pieces which
just have two colors
so i've sorted
the pieces into five piles that have
four pieces each
and now we're going to solve
we're going to explain how the layer
method works to solve the puzzle
the first step is we're going to look at
the white center the white face and
we're going to make a cross
so we're going to look at the edge
pieces
and we want to match the edge pieces
which have two colors
to the s to the sides to the other
center pieces which don't move
so here we have an orange and white edge
piece
and it has to go in that position
to match the white orange and white
sides
similarly the next side
has green and white
and we're going to keep going around the
rest of the layer
so we put the red and white edge piece
in position
and finally we put the blue and white
edge piece in position
and at this time we've solved
the white cross
the next step in the layer method
will be
to solve for the corner pieces
of the white layer
so there are four corner pieces and
we're going to find the group of corner
pieces
which have the white corners
so here we have an orange
and white and
green side
so there's one corner which has these
colors
and we put it in the correct orientation
then we have
a corner which is green
red and white
we find that corner
and put it in the correct orientation as
well
as you can see while i'm putting the
cube back together there are some
difficulties so that's another problem
with this method
of cheating
all right we put in the red blue and
white
and now it's getting kind of hard to
hold this together but we only have one
corner to go and that's the
blue orange and white corner
so now we put
it's falling apart
we'll put it back together all right so
now we've solved
one layer of the cube so all of these
pieces are in the correct position
and they match
not only is the white all of the
pieces on the white side white
but they also match
the center pieces for the colors of the
other side and that's very important
the next step in the layer method will
be to solve for the middle layer
so there are four pieces which have two
colors each
and we're going to want to match the
sides of the two colors
so we get the group of pieces there are
four of them
here we want to match a green and orange
edge piece in the middle layer
so we'll find that piece and then put it
in the correct orientation
we'll continue going around the middle
layer
we want to match an orange
and blue piece in the correct
orientation
we'll continue matching a blue
and red piece
and finally
we have a red and green piece
so once we put that piece into place we
have solved
the second layer and now we have two
layers completely solved we have the
bottom layer and the middle layer
we only have one more layer to solve
which is the yellow side
and we're going to solve that by
creating a cross
so we'll go ahead and match
the edge pieces
which have yellow on one side
and match it to the color of the other
side
we're going to go around the rest of
this layer and put in the remaining edge
pieces
when we actually solve the videos for
the top layer
we're going to do it slightly
differently we're going to create this
yellow cross without regard to matching
the other sides
but then we're going to show you how you
can
move these pieces around so ultimately
you will create a yellow cross where all
of the edge pieces match the center
pieces
of the sides
so we just have one more piece which is
the blue and yellow piece
it becomes harder
to start putting these pieces in as
all the other pieces are in the cube
but i'm gonna go ahead and try and snap
this into place
and all right i've actually made a
mistake here i've put it upside down
and
if you if you do make a mistake like
that while putting the cube back
together it's very important
that
you put it in the correct position
and the reason is that if you flip one
of the pieces it actually puts the cube
in an unsolvable position
so go ahead and fix that
and
that's one problem if you take apart the
cube you could put it back together in
the wrong way
all right finally we have four corners
and we're going to match
the correct colors and put all of these
four corners into place
so as it's becoming physically harder to
snap the pieces in
it will also be
a little bit harder mechanically to
solve the cube as we get more and more
pieces because there's
we want to move these pieces around
without messing up the rest of the cube
but once you get it
finally done you put
the last piece in and you will have a
solved cube
so that's how you cheat at solving the
rubik's cube and in the remaining videos
i'll show you how you can solve the cube
the right way
by learning specific move combinations
to move the edge and corner pieces
around
i hope you like this video please click
through to watch the next video which
explains the move notation
please subscribe to my channel
you can support me on patreon to get
exclusive rewards catch me on my blog
mind your decisions
on twitter at preshtalwalker and you can
get my books listed on my website